[Music]
you know them once
you know them days you want things to
fall in place while keeping up with this
place you're trying to keep a smile on
that face so you're raving on the
weekday off that street and into this
raid fam hey what is up guys i'm kphd
here and
an mkbhd merch store
this has never really been a thing in
the past we've had a couple things like
a single limited edition t-shirt on
teespring or some small fun creative
projects and those are always really
exciting but i've always wanted
something a little more permanent a
little more developing and a little more
interactive so this is gonna be that
taking it to the next level this is
something we haven't done before so this
is something that's been brewing for a
while you might have seen some of it
teased in the backgrounds of some videos
kind of showing up here and there but i
figured what better way to launch this
whole thing than
by reviewing my own merch
[Music]
the logo
the classic
not everyone will know
but you'll know so the shirt itself is
actually
really soft and this isn't something
that i had much control over with
previous shirts that i've done but this
is really nice material shirt like how
can something so crispy be so soft so
the material is 50 polyester 25 cotton
25 ryan that's why it's so soft and also
i'm 6'3 i'm wearing the large right now
you could probably get away with the
medium if you're my size also because
it's not going to shrink much it's
definitely a slim fit it's like a more
modern fit design for a t-shirt and
there's also different designs or
different fits for the men's versus
women so that's cool and it's also this
is a water-based ink so what that means
is instead of like a normal cheap screen
print design this isn't going to crack
and scrape off over time it's actually
going to get softer and still look this
good but the color scheme the design
the logo obviously i'm a pretty big fan
of this one
[Music]
the chevron this is another graphic
staple of the channel because obviously
it's in the channel banner
uh but i'm no fashion expert but this is
also a pretty
flattering like a sleek sort of modern
image i think it's a couple different
shades of red as you can see it's a warm
design and i feel like it could also be
pretty good for a couple other different
color combos also i don't know if you
picked up on this but every single one
of these shirts at the bottom down here
has this hem tag so every single shirt
has a hem tag with the logo on the
outside and established 2008 on the
other side
that is definitely a pretty nice touch
i'm glad we went with this
established 2008 this is another pretty
clean design
again pretty simple pretty soft again
it's got the hem tag again it's i and
this is actually i like it more than i
thought i would wearing it it looks
pretty dope another fun fact is all the
shirts on the inside usually you have
like a tag like a paper tag
sort of cuts you or is scratching you on
the back of the neck these shirts don't
have an actual physical tag instead this
one's got a little printed tag on the
inside with the size and the company's
logos and a little message for whoever
buys it so definitely pretty clean and
soft all the way around there have
obviously been many milestones in the
history of the channel the 100th video i
ever made the 100th subscriber video i
made update 1.0 about four years ago
today was when the channel first passed
one million subscribers which is huge
but i think the day that this channel
was first signed up the day it was
created on youtube is the biggest one of
them
[Music]
black everything
this one
this one is legit this is also the only
shirt of the collection that is 100
cotton so it may shrink a little bit
more but that's so that this is an
actually matte black shirt which is dope
uh maybe a little bit tough for pet
owners i could see that being a bit of a
problem but overall
the design clearly thought out well
there are only so many truths in life
and one of them is that every device
should have some sort of a stealthy or
space gray or matte black option
so that's why we made this and also uh
the hemp tag is probably the most
colorful part of this one
she's on my brain five shots
the hat that's right it's not just
t-shirts there's a hat as part of the
collection as well this one is it's like
a soft fabric on the outside it's a snap
back so one size fits
most and this actually isn't the only
color there's a little green in the brim
there but there's also going to be a
heather gray version and a navy blue
version so if black isn't your style
then you can get those colors as well
but
if you're a hat person there it is i bet
you've never seen me with a hat on i've
probably not since the golf videos on
the beginning of my channel have i had a
hat on in a video so that's it that's
the core that's what we're starting with
right now it is all live at
shop.mkbhd.com pretty glad we got that
url as well and the goal of this isn't
just to open a merch store and then you
guys get stuff and it ends there that's
the way a lot of things go but this is
more kind of like the channel like an
exchange so we have this sort of a core
collection of the beginning of things
but then as you guys come up with ideas
for maybe not just new designs but new
pieces or things you want to get and you
leave them in the comments that's kind
of like the way it's contributed to the
videos and the way i make videos that'll
add to the merch store as well so we'll
be adding things over time to what we've
established today i also want to give a
huge shout out to cotton bureau for
making this entire thing possible so
this is a cotton bureau site they're the
ones that make the beautiful web design
possible for that url they're the ones
that make the super soft shirts and that
top-notch quality possible and they're
the ones that make the worldwide
shipping of these being available
internationally possible so they're
taking care of shipping and getting it
to you guys as quickly as possible now
always shipping is going to be starting
off it's going to be going out in waves
so if you want to get your order in by
the first wave and get your stuff in
that first wave you have to order by
february 27th by 8 pm eastern that's
when the first wave ends and everything
goes through to production and gets
shipped so the hype is real for that i
can't wait to see you guys rocking these
but until the next one thank you for
watching oh and uh seems like a good
time to introduce the next milestone for
the mkbhd channel introducing the mkbhd
video team
thanks for watching
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]